[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah that's new for Instagram TV yeah
what so fool podcast
what's our full podcast welcome everyone
to the word so full podcast we have a
lot of people today man first of all we
have the co-host of the year and the
co-host of the week and the co-host of
the half a year March of rizzo people
yeah three more toys right here Johnny
Rock was our next victim at you know
pillow fight the night before we yeah
what the feather is so inside the pillow
so you're gonna shave your head I want
to I'm waiting for a reason to bring his
Clippers over you know shave your head
yeah yeah you wants to look like a month
did Johnny when I first met him
where do you live I live over off Ching
ghazal boulevardier was unless Ricky
like Kramer you gotta borrow everything
twin is a replacement tell the story of
the jacket how you lost that jacket it
all happened with the collagen eye beam
last year when we were doing the Irvine
improv and then I'd be able to say that
70,000 anyway now when I say it there in
front of you
my jagged zinho doesn't you lost like
all the weight in stealing your fashion
man when you got moves like Rizzo you
put on a jacket that were a certain
order you lost weight big clothing
that's what Johnny - this makes me look
like shoulders yeah man the only word a
jacket or your pants no and I'm not the
pants right now
yeah I stole those khakis when I was
movie and I take all I couldn't find
these khakis and then I saw you weigh no
like they look tight on you bro I know
but they were good they hug you know
what the right place what's a full
podcast oh man
so um crazy things have been happening
this week um we found out that our green
land is not for sale
no just wow so mad no no ready to buy it
do a head like five hundred twenty three
billion dollars also the Amazon is on
fire bro it's no burning yeah bro that's
what looks like when I smoke a bowl and
I think our friends offered to give them
21 million dollars and France European
and Brazil said Charlie we're gonna be
no colony chunks oh damn
they're trying to expand their interest
you trying to give their money together
they've got all that money for less
normally know they always thing and that
was Tom Philippe yesterday's they're
good you know expand their interests
their if they're already there yeah just
gonna expand that should they get your
to open up a baguette nothing's free dog
nothing then you get used to that money
too as a country and then they try to
pull it away as sanctions and that sort
of thing you know and he's sort of aid
they'll start to cut off or they'll
start to use it politically well just
have to pull our funding I mean in the
air man like like wow you have Brazil
right you say they say yeah yeah three
or four 21 million but that's not so
anyone really [ __ ] Rose do you put up
that fire bro how mother took us to turn
down the fire here in California
probably more than that we have more
resource mobis don't even cost me 1
million Oh me about putting it out my
key morale is your price compared yeah
but you're thinking in terms of damage
to them when we have fires we have
damage that's what the costs go to like
all the homes that are low yeah I mean
like technically damage wise there's
probably not much like businesses and
buildings and homes but rabbits there is
eco the ecosystem that's more important
than monetary value you know you can't
really put a price on it
you know but the other states in Brazil
the other heads of those states are
saying please let's say yes to them
money because they think it's gonna be
helpful but then the other thing too is
they said that you know crooked
Brazilian politicians don't line their
pockets with all the eight I don't know
his name but he's a the right-wing
opposition to the what was in there
before the liberal staffer can pick
office and that I got a molecular yeah
but the people saying dude the crime is
like ramp it we got to do something but
I was talking with a cab driver Jerry
he's AA man it's just a cleansing down
there in a mess
I don't think he's how I don't think
he's all wrong yeah maybe you know they
want to help these people want to help
with money but I think that leader is
probably looking at this as an
opportunity because he's saying that
they lit it on fire just to make them
look bad that's like I mean that's where
the cook you know that Popeye sandwich
is a farmer started those fires by their
own I don't think they should all happen
like by itself can't do by dropping the
signal yeah what happened what happened
all the time ago how's the case you know
like fires you can live like tribesmen
still right there's supposed a hunt
they let them leave let that yeah
they're there I want to be there
protected by the country yeah yeah there
are certain areas that are protected not
only I'm not everything but it'll pay
taxes no they're indigenous so the other
guy yeah but but they also have cut
budgets four years have cut the
deforestation budget IRA cut the budget
again so they don't haven't kept up the
forest either which is I think why all
this got out of hand but I don't know
there hasn't been a lot of talk about
the origin whether it is these these
farmers like you were saying or if
somebody lit it to make them look bad or
say you can see from space for a whole
year just you know that I've been ready
for 10 years they don't know what the
body that's not really our problem right
not like jumping to help 21 million is
not gonna do anything to the Amazon but
this is like 40% of the Oxford sucks 40%
of oxygen produced came from seaweed
yeah
thank you I thank you for those fast
oxygen is given off by plants yeah
greenery it's given off by greenery but
and then we breathe out co2 when we
exhale and that helps feed the plants
not just the horn house you pay for it
if you see the porno star the big
company last night at the comedy
Palestine what was his end there he came
up Barlow and Jeffrey Peters it bro had
a vision but I think that's one of those
fools a did this video like you [ __ ]
around the truth man I've seen your film
whoo here we go up to a porn starts say
I really like a male porn star I see
Johnny Mont mountain I would tell that's
a newscaster
yeah yeah yeah the harmonica for us do
it all and his appearances and stuff if
he's really cheap he doesn't have to get
a side job but if he really had a real
lifestyle and a home and like a family
or what he'd have to have a second yeah
he takes his hopes from the hotel yeah
he does those porn conventions really
those those guys it takes money to make
we're gonna kamikaze oh people do you
think there was ever a one Pig huh yeah
yeah you know I would have [ __ ] lived
in Texas I just those two commercials
out E and the McDonald's I would have
liked you had a booth British people
were taking pictures of you all that
that's the epic
there scream there's a kid saying that
that guess I need to do it though sure
you yes you will make a [ __ ] demon
how do they burst it down and put that
Porter that little Ajani from [ __ ] in
Miami fellas and after waiting since our
boom yeah and then a photo with it with
MC punches house MC so you need right
that's how you need from people if I can
get it out man
that's all you fool how about we just
make [ __ ] Johnny that fool dog yeah we
get the money that's all you need
yeah there's quick money right for those
people
oh yeah just pictures remember for 15
years Johnny right there funny huh
Godfather and he's telling it that's a
lovely line and then like the [ __ ] you
know the do take so ha and he on a
killer the money you guys you'll be
together for the moon that's me and
that's Johnny used to be a big guy now
I'm a small guy
yes driving to the open mic cut the
Clippers Dean it'll be blahs
I need a cut to you know sad pick it up
Frank severe severe oh no this is my
beautiful little sister do he was so
funny if I in the wedding yes watch the
game up it's a badass movie with that
fool dog he's just a teach hey Philippe
I need some extra virgin olive oil I
don't want to be known as a
brother-in-law to the local nutcase you
know he sued The Simpsons for them still
in his character is like and that's why
Sam Simon's in the [ __ ] care
please that nerve the glasses yeah and
the Yankee hat yeah I seen that rerun I
mean I didn't understand what he said
back to my self custody mr. meow you
killed their happy days man and he
killed in Sanford asunto yeah and he was
a good Santa commute use phone yeah
what's the name discovered although who
did Fred Santa mr. me I was his real
name [ __ ] bat buried in Panama Reno
the absolutely other Santa's on first
happy days every son and then they will
all know the happy day yeah you use a
comedian from San Francisco that's is uh
sorry in San Francisco we have to kick
out a couple of comedians out of San
Jose improv robes just standing there
watching the host shocking reality what
are you doing here man I'm learning bro
I'm a regular comic knowing all your
boys I remember no no I remember we
didn't sound was he a long time ago and
now one big comedian big warm was out
there is a freedom and they you told to
go walk out as you remember and people
were like what I see the lady say he did
not get that fat guy pretend it was
yellow here yeah he was like I was super
humongous really what he wanted fools in
are like so fat that they have long hair
but it's yeah people are clapping and
they stop cuz wallow Felipe big war
wound up there never clapping like all
happy there's a pretty sorry for me
well I should've clever pieces yeah cuz
it was a big old fat lady that said oh
my god he did not get that fat and
they're bugging out there a bus driver
lady
therefore they became on everybody
dialing yes I let myself go huh Mike but
what would the follow they doing there
brother that like no respect to the game
bro like you wouldn't do that for the
other comedians wait right there in a
green by the [ __ ] stage with a
comedian I ready to go up you see how
big is your eye cream movie wait to see
you if I was like that and I'll just
give you a fat ass bomb joint and walk
away I know my sure you stay in San Jose
kiss at each forget drop kick to the
chest so what's up well hello Portland I
don't know Johnny was going he's the
world yeah alone bro let a breeze dog it
was a we we saw bright two years
anniversary me and Stephanie yeah we got
we stayed at the alphabet district
Johnny said me and my girlfriend us
around - yeah we stayed at the it's very
good I got like because I'm such an LA
guy I was just
[Laughter]
I was comparing [ __ ] a poorly to
[ __ ] like Elliott man isn't looking
out - dino-man of town with you yeah
Kenyatta right here yeah Montrose yeah
why the way do we go over here to the
play without the gunships the couny ship
their army how's Ryan Beach yeah that
one go that is a badass strip club in
Portland oh we didn't go Lisa told me
about to own it it's over the port is a
vegan now yeah let's go - I didn't
realize how [ __ ] small Portland is
cuz we walked from downtown to our
Airbnb and it was like only like [ __ ]
a mile from [ __ ] downtown it's so
small and it's all just founded by woods
but we had a lot of [ __ ] a good food
out there everything's sending around
the bridges and the wall yeah and then
after that uh you have being a barbecue
yeah we have vegan barbecue at Johnny
yeah and his sister at uh what's up
let's go home girl and then my next
swords like this don't only find out
that a yacht in [ __ ] Portland wasn't
legit it was legit bros [ __ ] like
actual [ __ ] like there's like nothing
but hipsters eating in that place like
it was like legit like ghetto Mexican
right you know it was cool man I liked
it we said this quote Airbnb doesn't
first time there within a house or
apartment it was a Congo yeah yeah it
was kids you guys the [ __ ] older than
us I don't know you got
Behrman bring this up for people out to
who order air B&B read everything before
you say yes to there's a lot of tax it's
about taxes
[ __ ] your rules and some of the rules
you just like you don't want the rules
like camber man he already got one where
they have to be in by by by 11:00 on
Friday Thursday every every night every
night and it was in Brooklyn Manhattan
by 10:00 I thought it was a city that
never sleeps 10:30 but it was hopefully
the problem was it wasn't a he chose the
cheapest option which is what Martin and
Johnny were renting out which is a room
inside your apartment so he rented out a
room inside an apartment with his female
cousin so I think he slept on the floor
and she slept on the bed in there what
am I gonna do with this hard-on that's
why they had the rules because those
people had to work the next day no no no
just meet her no filming no filming yeah
no John no he'll be out if they go no
far T no I was crazy when we air B&B the
booking room cuz I mean John clean the
room and we're like the other room he he
took a picture though like it looked
like a [ __ ] like the held hostages
old curtains on LA right yes so I want
to go by new curtains new sheets for the
bed and made for the Airbnb room and
good way nicer than they did before and
then yeah man last long oh [ __ ] kickers
are walk in there you go ever
yeah yeah people came through I read the
reviews people are happy there's a good
place to put your head [ __ ] this will do
the air B&B from the gather already yeah
probably eventually what that's whywe
kicked out no no that guy was on board
to that foot was collecting most of
money no yeah I keep that because uh the
roommate he was he didn't like that
Johnny uh Tony McLean oh yeah dirty-ass
pool huh
yeah we're gonna we're talk about tying
a mop and clean in front of them no
clean no dog
it's not in my Constitution dirty my
phone yeah Daniel what's up what's up oh
I'm gonna be in Arlington Virginia at DC
area
Arlington Trap House this is the comedy
club that's also a movie theater during
the day so you can watch like old movies
for like 10 bucks buy a beer and watch
the movie get up no actually you could
have your own picture of beer here so if
anybody out there who have never been to
like a place like this they want to come
to the show and DC to be a nice
experience man 21st okay now we're gonna
start from the beginning this weekend
I'll be in Philadelphia helium comedy
club August 32 a September 1st the one
America September 4th and Antigua both
they got a papal seal a classical will
be there man with was eat eat tacos it
might be vegan also Lancaster California
Lancaster Performing Arts Center
Antelope Valley Comedy Festival
September 7 almost sold out this is a
good show if you have a part of the
Lancaster comedy festival if you buy a
ticket for my show that take it we'll
get you in free to all the other shows
you want to go to and you can vote on
the people you want to win this comedy
contest were rooting for Jose Villasenor
name
no Sarah Louise Louise Villasenor
shout-out to Louise Villasenor horn
English cultures like the last couple of
years know the Reno he didn't win so uh
so hopefully man we could help your
women cook we give a guest spot and you
get your boat forever even let me go to
the show it is vote for him
hey if you wanna get together win bad
yeah yeah if we're gonna help a win we
don't get a cut bro I remember when I
met Louise of yes Senor
I saw him damn bro you like a clean
belly man now ie Pechanga come because I
remember we were doing the I were to
leaves one time the only time I was I
should [ __ ] far bro oh yeah 450 bucks
and I saw Louise via Senor showed up
with Carla Carla Loma comedian from the
IE also Pomona and they have back pastor
Willie Barcena I brought like brand new
ones like a Willie Barcena steady any
backpacks ball any shoulder backpacks
just click your vendor with their notes
and their backpacks you know like the
side bags right I got like a like a mail
bag and they both had one satchel
satchel and they came in and they were
the only ones with a buck there's
actually like a joke to write on or
paper and I'm looking at they going man
I'm saying a word here Olivia were good
inside of it you know Willie Barcena bro
we're update update where what happened
what happened bro
well sources say that on ABC News with
Walter Cronkite II know yeah Roger go
newzik that's the word on the street all
right tap for sources to sources don't
want to speak are not on the condition
of anonymity but on the condition of I
guess I don't have anything for of me to
other sources well I don't know
bird told me you got arrested at the
airport
yeah they got him at the airport you see
somebody somebody they know the victim
might have fun are they were gonna be
there call somebody I think they got too
cocky and then he like advertised like a
month before and they calculated it and
you know you gotta get them I think I
think that in the in the little [ __ ]
with a man you doing nothing it's
already been two months in there twice
and he's coming man visitor before yeah
two times I do too it's arrested yeah
but I don't think the cops are thinking
oh he should I call his tore the Teflon
dog dog dude like you know like [ __ ]
the killer Bundy you gotta get going
sneak out through the air conditioning
so he gets arrested and then the comic
that was with him supposedly put up his
house the person you're talking about
old his house and his my Luna back no no
well the person that got arrested that
seems to be the case but I guess that's
not the case cuz he didn't put his house
up the other comic put his house up for
him but the thing is Willie's not
returning phone calls to another
comedian that's gonna be working with
him soon because he's out on the lam or
he's actually incarcerated because he
doesn't want to run on homeboys bail so
I mean this is again allegedly so you
can't sue us you got to sue NBC but yeah
so that's what's going on weekly a word
on damn imagine you that comedian that
had - that's what - supposed to have
your house to build a wheelie bar say
yes people do you think he can really
call to ask for a favor let's hear that
whose mom probably taught him to go to
hell huh I don't think there's one comma
K you know that would do that I would do
it for anybody
my family gonna take it like it's the
only way I will do that if it's his mom
staying at my house and that food scares
I'm a punch of pain
but if he's serving the time right now
or you say he's like locked up right now
mm-hmm
and he gets busted for assault or
aggravated assault or whatever it was
the guy that took pictures of his
markings you know the victim so to speak
I think the most thing you can probably
get is what oh wait 60 days nothing or
nothing
first-time offender intentions they
can't bring old stuff from California
cuz you guys know the part the son was
in law school right when he was working
after at the club yeah well Bart Reed's
sons a prosecutor now so maybe he's
giving some inside information on how to
fight or to lay low and we'll you know
watch the silver but who knows he's
probably an intra introductory
prosecutor not on the high level you
know but who knows you know I don't know
but uh yeah what's it for update oh no
how common are those bar fights in El
Paso hey bro my shooter was a big
brother what happened at that Walmart
but you brag about people you know but I
mean you know I think somebody called
and said who's gonna be there cuz nobody
no cops are going we're gonna catch get
on this opener that that comedian who
put the bill replace another conspiracy
theory I learned for you bro
I remember how about making oh [ __ ] I
caught both of those fools up and
they're acting dumb dumb oh no I didn't
hear about I remember I was like yeah
right bro I remember I got yeah that's
it like a fan listen to like the podcast
while we talk about Willie and it's only
message Willie I showed you the message
is a message Willie a bro uh my rizal's
coming for you
I'm just kidding I'm a big fan man keep
it up bro and then he sent me that the
screech oh they broke the [ __ ] is this
you talking shilling bro you don't sound
the [ __ ] Internet we're getting your
friends after me bro that's what I was
thinking about what the guy put his
house up I don't understand that because
how much could that bail have been yeah
I think he probably $10,000 and put on
down mm and then Willy's probably
staying in jail to get that jail credit
that's what I think we my joke credit
because knocked off yeah so when you get
a sentence and say give you 20 days bro
I've been here 26 you guys only six days
simple mathematics well funny drama
though haha but that means that he said
though it means you say no to bail no
whoa at least take bail and like get out
and then just I mean I don't know what
the [ __ ] so it's chaotic bro yeah it's
pretty threatening do well he could go
to jail for that dog
you could go to Facebook jail yeah
listen to miss brandy so that's him
right there tightening chin a send you
the screenshot all right
you saying his voice why is one of your
friends talking [ __ ] to me bro what the
[ __ ] is up with that [ __ ] bro this is uh
missus missus why we're not gonna outer
Martin Rizzo is gonna take your place in
the Latin his [ __ ] panic
Chicano a comedy world your comedy is
getting old hey bro baby doll you're
confused not miss white puts but I'm
pretty sure your son's can be
yeah and then the guy throws yeah yeah
put the famous elbows from Cali from La
Paz Oh bro [ __ ] off and then and then
then he says to you on the text do we
have a problem I didn't know about don't
know what to say to other comedians bro
now when it comes to stuff like that
that's all completely safe they just
don't know what to say like however I
had to follow I don't know if it will II
would for the hood but not the one for
the Willie Willie would enough Inland
Empire the real one the original guitar
was scary wooly Willy yeah Willy rocked
it bro little no no no Brown no yeah he
will be brought here original I went up
after him right and they're like of Cour
he killed it and they had just turned
out the Laker game so this [ __ ] chola
nothing like my jobs brother she wearing
our Laker doubt bro now she's about to
sleep with a towel boy from the lake
when a forum getting on Sheneneh amen
you large homes I see no other safe sock
we're not [ __ ] funny
get the [ __ ] out of here like she was
open Mikey heckling bro first time
heckling and she know what to say
so she was annoying me anyways though
you a man you're done homes
you lost days now look I beat you way I
would important to a guy beat you ate
would waterboard that chick with a
schooner dog you know how to yeah you
lost a competition that is there's no
competition [ __ ] you win but you kicked
her ass I forget about homework to kill
you and shoot your ass you're gonna lose
for real
[Laughter]
man it's better a bagging on her heart
and it kicked her ass out she always
said waiting for like 30 minutes then
this tires are just getting her car and
go home and kids with kids in the
forehead and say good night
one of those fats one of the dirty house
they don't know how to socialize huh no
she was you know juice champ chubby but
she won with a bunch of dudes and I
guess you'll get another attention but
then it was all gone ones real talent
when I pass well funny but you lost they
beat you you just ghetto people like
that they would he beat me at [ __ ] what
[ __ ] you okay I lose their portrait
like if she works I got a restaurant but
they don't give me props in Oxnard when
I was opening up for fluffy and then I
fooled like ah you killed they hold me
you should have been the main liner
don't need air the main liner breath did
a headliner the mainlander what the
death wasn't no [ __ ] prison like
wouldn't nobody [ __ ] with him that's the
main being yeah man what's up fool we
got distracted but I'm coming back to
Vegas Treasure Island September 13th
Sacramento the crest theater September
14 Kaaba stone California on this show
is almost sold out morongo casino
September 15 our Paso Texas we're gonna
go what I'm Willie Barcena on Court TV
watching live September 27 at the fly
Plaza theater Corpus Christi Texas
September 28th at Salina auditorium
American Bank Center Los Angeles
Microsoft theatres October 4th
hey bro tell your leader do me a foundry
they're gonna create servers on stage
well whoever built him out man I hope
that for very appreciative of doing of
him doing that but that's uh yeah that's
a big one he has a lot of fans out there
that will bail him out dude maybe I
still got somebody got somebody well I'm
hoping to put my one-day magic [ __ ]
don't go down I'm gonna leave with
somebody backyard low-flying Eiffel do
look back your comments over here pull
out some old email for something you
said man you said you have three extra
row of the Lancaster according to this
document a Chicano people actually email
me say man you know man I know you know
you gotta come in Chicago man and we
have two extra rules you're the real can
have right so where we actually took of
the ralpher bro something like that
where I show up to their house and they
just are 14 [ __ ] my underwear you
either the Mike moment I'm trying to
listen land of misfit toys over what
happened over there bro was wrong but
what a long face trying to think about
these fans inviting you guys over no
fans invited
I invite myself but with Toby Hicks
ah is blessed to be out here in mcallen
law I needed this you got the late huh
fool what happened but I don't know what
how many if I gonna know Oh America come
on
I'm did I get it yeah I gotta be chill
but then I was going dude this should
get some lady like that other time we're
gonna have to drive
what do you mean hours from here you
ain't gonna make notes out you guys
drove through the snow no we
from Austin to Houston so then we hop up
the ladies I'll check it out if that one
doesn't come through and gets cancelled
I'm gonna put you on a 408 flight and
that'll get you there about half hour
before your show I'm all cool and then
she's all excuse me mr. reso yeah she
looked them up as mr. Herrera it's nice
to know you have another name I've
always had two names [ __ ] alien tax
paperwork but I when I when I asked him
what should I book you under he said
Martin Rizzo because my ID says Martin
Rizzo it's always Rizzo
my name is Larry but to say I need a
habit Lawrence Lawrence well that was
that was a stupid person who didn't know
that Larry was a nickname Lauren yeah
but she was she was out of shoes at the
airport this weekend too I'm like all
right [ __ ] it dude hey so he has to go
to ticketing um I'll just use my credit
card and I was like you know what all
right [ __ ] it just call it what's crazy
though it's it's it was not possible and
I kept asking the woman I said house is
possible this is the second leg of one
it does have a same confirmation number
but it's saying not paid my whole thing
is how did he get to point a I said I
booked all those guys flights the same
way there's no she said that's how it is
ma'am I was ladies dumb dude I never
that yeah yeah how the [ __ ] they go
through security you have I know but
immediately after her era I bought the
new leg of the flight uh-huh she told
Martin oh I found you here or whatever
because she I mean she saw the
confirmation the confirmation was
updated yeah it doesn't make any sense
and at the hotel last night she kept
playing with a credit card it cars being
denied the problem
I took quiet so you paid for San Diego
eyes thank you
so he paid for okay good job let's see
my whole thing is like alright what if
that's the case we got to solve I don't
think what if we miss the [ __ ] show
dog and it's like oh my god industry was
here time to call people from McAllen
yeah you know what luckily you were
delayed because because of that issue we
would have had it you only had 40
minutes yeah would have popped up and
that would have delayed nothing and I'm
just like dude I'm over here thinking
about all right dude let me just go get
a read on [ __ ] and so it's seven hours
from here the lady says even if I've to
steal plane tell me this wants to go
home she pops up dog and you gotta adapt
dogs and then we're on the run always
gonna have lease on the phone like to be
all like all this wool what he doesn't
know what's [ __ ] cracking we gotta
solve it dog if not what the [ __ ] and
then we're on the runway for a long time
25 minutes and that was another delay so
we got there we just we went straight to
the yeah and then Toby had a go shower
it's like fool your tooth with a wet rag
rolls no hand table you bite your nails
oh yeah yeah put polish oh go take you
serious like that's why you ain't
married
I need to get a manicure so why my
outfit you know they put on this little
polish on there you gonna bite it is
gonna taste nasty no it's only like I
mean I know a lot of brothers get it
done and they go get marry have nice
long nails but you know you got a little
itty bitty ends so those hands should
stay how they are you know yeah those
are like for action figures yeah I told
me I was like hi etiquette those
asymmetric boys okay you can't cough at
the table you can't sneak oh you go tell
dude and I drop like three M&Ms and I
picked them up a name I can't believe I
don't adapt my acclimate growing up
you got three I know my name's my dad
trying to pick that [ __ ] up and eat it
right away every nice people you get the
part that I like oh it's a three-second
rule
I don't know I'm gonna build a party and
either
eight clear off the trash can bro like
George Costanza it depends on how big
that you got you
it's not bad that donut could be inside
of a new donut box oh it was a [ __ ]
blast it was a third of Hawaii what it
was like inside a wrapper surprise are
you a tragic one time oh it was good I
work at the restaurant call Jose's dog
and they have those uh those uh come on
a table and they had on my local yokel
some lady ate one dog and they come with
25 well I had 24 that day took it to the
back full - you know I had that food put
some more sauce on for me did you say
that somebody complain I choked eat
cheese because if we're at a party and
then we eat our pizza and then we'll do
the pizza behind and they found out that
somebody kind of leftover pizza a minute
oh no get it wait a minute man diamond
slice makes it is a symmetrical I'm
gonna hexagon here when you go to Chuck
E Cheese the pizzas never all the pieces
never match up and people are saying
that oh maybe [ __ ] they just get like
leftover pizzas they make a pizza and
there's video of people going to [ __ ]
Chuck E Cheese and they're like oh my
gosh what the [ __ ] and they came out
with the same insane that they used that
one [ __ ] a pizza cutter that one's
kind of like that yeah yeah it's like a
rockin yeah but that they cut it before
they bake the [ __ ] pizza and it's
still doughy so it's like why the [ __ ]
do you kind of like that what are you
doing a [ __ ] cheese anyways with a
little ass I have nieces and nephews so
the cheese bar oh man let me take that
great right now the Mojo's you grew up
on top shake shake shake
so I was telling you guys they're like
bunch of lunch they don't make it as
good as they make the regular Shakey's
Pizza and Mojo's they want you to throw
along
no they look they're like [ __ ] India
they make those things cheap little
shaky the only thing now shake it like
it's like Chuckie Cheese you gotta get
make up an animal their mother you know
they know there's no mascot Rogers video
games no the fried chicken is the [ __ ]
to dog company they fry potatoes at the
way they fried chicken yeah put in a
flower place on the road on the Turnpike
Jersey Turnpike going down to Atlantic
City from New York and I used to always
stop there and get the fried chicken
fries and their potatoes but they've
been fried with a batter for the fried
chicken don't go to a little jar ranch
they were I remember my friends went to
a Shakey's and my friends were like dude
and make you free Mojo's every give you
refills on mojo's you know it's a [ __ ]
yeah so we just we got there together
the Mojo's you forgot a piece that we
just ate the Mojo's right away like we
ready for a refill
I'm Freddy
shake you with the first place I ever
had blue cheese dressing oh yeah and
then after that is a [ __ ] yeah they're
blue cheese taste exactly I bought big
boy blue cheese that's good that's good
dressing because they said I say they're
brothers they come in the little jars
but whatever my dad sure my dad like
blue cheese so mother he went home and
bought wishbone which whole sauce dude
it is squirt bottle [ __ ] dressing can
I only like it on cop salads I like blue
cheese and then hit it ranch was the
best Brad killing the game
fool with pizza on the first time
[ __ ] meta [ __ ] ranch with pizza oh
[ __ ] he said ranch with pizza oh my god
absolution area I know the first time I
had rags with fries with in Tucson
Arizona and that's good to you jeez shut
up to a G's in Tucson they make fries
with everything Manor they make pizza
fries they have mozzarella much much
mozzarella and
pepperoni's they have garlic fries and
they have a Parmesan cheese fries but
what I had was garlic fries bombs bacon
bits on top my ranch like oh I was gonna
say you know what I was used to be good
back in the day and say that [ __ ] even
before we hit the pizza only crazy but
we're driving back we talked about crazy
bread for like 30 minutes when it's nice
and warm and fresh look easier totally
man [ __ ] a brazii bread dog the marinara
go yeah I get the quarter to get an
extra marinara but it was worth about a
nice thick and rich we did in old
country to a horrible just bread sticks
or just remember sticks you can just
order the breadsticks and be cool that
butter I do it's [ __ ] it's good but
even a little cheese two dogs a couple
slices I'll sound these guys I was
giving a lift to a couple and it was a
British guy and her wife was American
yeah and she was trying to explain to
him what Little Caesars why they did it
the British guys did that give the
little guy Pizza Pizza like I don't know
if the shady is great as pizza you ever
I say low Joe have you joke about how
Mexicans cut their pizza but I went to
go do a show in in [ __ ] in Tucson
right the last year and right next to us
there was a couple and the guy was like
I don't know who my age but older but he
was tall [ __ ] drunk as [ __ ] the
casino [ __ ] up the bedroom and he was
there with his mom and his daughter no
his mom and his son and his lady who
look like a wrecking ball
oh my - I saw here she's into it she's a
teacher
yeah and they're like why the way she
didn't do that oh I didn't go out there
and meet anybody but much of rizal run
into her right what happened wrong shoe
the water center of the room
Oh she came up to use older she said oh
okay so okay so we're okay so her why
this older [ __ ] she look like [ __ ]
original sin it was a ten yeah yeah that
messed up of a face yeah like she looks
like she'd the voice I've been drugged
went to cow Malibu in the 80s yeah poor
back though no smoker creases so I
remember I she came up to me and she was
I was at the merch stand where she's
like and I was like oh he's gonna come
out in a bit you should become I should
come out a bit and then after that she
2000 hopefully that last time I was here
cuz you're all we're staying in the same
hotel yeah and then that she I saw you
in the lobby and she took a picture with
you and she was calling her husband
telling me I'm Philippe is here so I
guess the husband was all drunk and
drugged up that he thought that you got
a hotel room there to [ __ ] be like no
and then he started looking at turning
up the room he forgetting [ __ ] up the
whole room Eurasia
in a raid drug and drug rage yeah like
he thought you was there like he's like
why the [ __ ] are you whenever Philippe
you know I hate a [ __ ] hotel you know
one of my life a whole horse and then he
just worked the whole [ __ ] uh the
whole room hotel room he got charged
like I've been like two thousand dollars
not an excuse to go party dog what the
[ __ ] each other yeah I know I would
you find any excuse to go [ __ ] disappear
right and yeah I guess he left but it
was still the credit card on there and
it she was there she's like yeah that
crazy story I'm run into the funny was
going on and I think she was still what
that guy I think I got was still there
corporal perfect love yeah
that's how we six months we have a big
fallout yeah
but that's crazy man like to think that
way that means he's doing [ __ ] yeah he
must have liked him like that
you know treasure deep something like
that crazy is that mean that he's done
that before
or takes off went that after you're
married though I could understand your
boyfriend got a hotel to here close to
the show that's right yeah the mom was
there he she was going to the show we
seen him the next morning and she was
telling him like the story cuz of this
mother yeah and then we were there were
little babies down because we at that
little buffet before it took off yeah
little story in the mom was I am yeah
Arizona people crazy that's something I
got a room bro she told him he's part of
the book club what's over that fool
brother they wanted to get your [ __ ]
window open bro
an airplane oh my god see and it's
happened before with the lady so I mean
I usually get the window you know think
thank the Lord
no thank the manager [ __ ] so so I'm
chillin right and this is the second
flight you know this book gives me a
little elder Edda ball a nice smooth one
dude that he [ __ ] I hooked up with
homeboy from up north and they were like
let's chill nothing [ __ ] dramatic and
crazy and the second flight I go in
there to sit down and then this little
[ __ ] little rabble rouser like little
[ __ ] Yosemite Sam with no mustache a
little a little old man on her tough you
said you he was probably tough he's the
probably talk [ __ ] to the wife used to
be these kids in the zoo but not tonight
bags sitting there right got my little
headphones on dude you know listening to
my tunes as we do and this was all right
can you pull up the window for kickoff
because I need to see you I need to see
the runway I need to see the sky I'm uh
no you should have bought a window seat
it's not happening today
dude I was like this was having a
tantrum and so I just like got my I
start rocking out though and then he
starts going at this you got no hair for
ya this is my little trick line that how
I put my seat back when the when the
airplanes taking off cuz they tell you
to put the seat up when it's taken off
and right when it lifts up and gets in
the sky I hit the little button I go
right so then he starts looking over oh
you hit that little button and in like
20 minutes later he like you know his
little you go got away from and he puts
a seat down there tiny little do dog
fight to you know meet back haha
I waited for this for to go to sleep me
kicking the theme or doing some toys me
as soon as I forget this drinking for
children sleeping and I just lean back
and make a I'm a cool [ __ ] dog
you're being a dick dude I'm gonna get
you some how does so then it's gonna be
use the restroom dog come back and wait
for that fool to go to sleep a game doc
at this time I gave him about five
minutes dog excuse me sir I gotta use
the little boy's room
whose I get up I let one rip dog and
this was when you're watching you know
mine are silent uh-oh
so we're getting ready to land I need
you to put the window up I was like that
part of tommy-boy food were they talking
about bo Derek he's off he's not drunk
I'm acting all dumb and it's all a man
like I said next time buy yourself a
window seat you can do whatever you want
with the window it's not happening today
maybe you know you're like that to your
kids and they do whatever you want but
you're not my father you told oh man it
is so funny because they can't do [ __ ]
dog if he gets crazy dog they'll tackle
them or we know as a team and then the
air marshals will get them and can never
fight again so chuckling my arms do what
you want but you're not gonna open the
window
and you're not gonna have your way
though now if he was nice hanging go how
about we switch seats $400 that's a
power know people like I'm gonna take
your novel this morning and there's one
dude on the other side with a window up
oh my god they just finished a your
stupid-ass lower them close the windows
cuz we're gonna keep the plane won't
cool
yeah remainder of the flight is hot oh
and you know what's funny about that oh
man he tried to tell the way to the
stewardess I can't do anything sure what
you need to do is get yourself some
headphones next time she keeps walking
like that you know helpful had nothing
no pornos newspaper a boy then he did in
a reverse eight
you got bored and hey you lost cattle
areas dog tortured himself I often feel
like doing stuff like that but then I
feel like I'm gonna run into this person
at some point I'm gonna need something
from them which I feel like I feel like
in LA when I cut somebody off or
something I have a big altercation on
the freeway or something like or you're
looking you're mad dogging somebody
after I cut them off or whatever I feel
like that person I'm gonna have a
meeting with that person at some point
you know they're gonna be the person I'm
meeting with you know our job interview
or whatever it might be and I'm gonna
because I just feel like it's my luck
well well well that's how I feel you
know I feel afraid to do something with
somebody like that cuz it'll come back
to me like he reminded me a cotton from
licking the hill cause he hit a little
high water pants I killed that you could
tell those were like the only shoes he
wears dog just needs a Popeye's Chicken
window-seat bro
and then like who got up and like his
wife was sitting over there bro he gave
me a little look if I'm gonna ask him if
he could sue his wife and I just look at
both of them I'll even look at her broad
you looked at him and just sat down and
closed my eyes separating families
problem we got children separated you
and I could be [ __ ] apart for a whole
[ __ ] two hour flight it's not gonna
happen in my watch some guy has been all
about to get my middle seat you know how
a guy sitting there with a lady and he
goes oh man oh honey if I could see cuz
I was there no other I was sitting at
the same aisle and I sort of only you
say pretty please
easy nothing else yeah and if you're
pretty please all right damn
I'll get softer universe yeah
if they ask me dog and I don't want to
move up you like to listen what I say oh
please in the conversation cuz I further
did the one that winning in this deal
brought up you know at I'm pretty
pushing therefore gonna say thank you
either dogs well I'm not gonna give a
window seat for an IOC over or a middle
seat
but I also gonna give for an American
Airlines or Delta going we're not flying
Southwest today from this is sciencv
that's a verbal verbal currency right
there there you go rights like Bitcoin
but it works yeah exactly I'm cuss at
each I'll be sitting notice always will
be long saving this seat yeah yeah you
take it no I don't want no [ __ ] to
deal with that [ __ ] dog even though
but you know they'll start telling them
that you can't save the seats and then
some Pinot Noir waiting rooms not sorry
but you got to make it for this person
so we lost every seats no the no saving
seats to over gets up a lot though he
has to let out that little beer from his
little what does that call where you
hold your hey Toby's not here Toby's not
naturally skinny I think salads all the
time he eats fruits he doesn't he bread
yeah well you see he's an alien
no catch no life I want to see picture
when he was a little kid dog yeah we're
gonna do from still more at the in
mcallen oh yeah I thought miss Phinney
very much for bringing us those tapes
hell yeah for what's up doc say that
super happy man they went to the noble
theatre last year yeah we minute and we
made a couple at the end of the show
forgot their name oh yeah come on yeah
yeah I was cool man
then we made out and then we did there's
love bit to make day right in and out
huh
yeah myeloma Buddy Holly my [ __ ]
heart huh yeah dude I like to impossible
burgers yeah we can I got to get order
bro hungry yeah I would really good no
you were starving Portland but I ate it
after what we have the day before that
though we had a kebabs right
Mediterranean PMS rayon food
with alright with Charlie Manson but
nothing beats those are all you guys
chose the wrong time to be vegan man yes
laughter Popeye's Chicken
they were now right good dude
so I had to go to the one in Boyle
Heights that's open 24 hours
what's it called what are you for our
pizza pie that's a causation from the
hospital yeah I'm I'm Ranko yeah so I
went long line loving Lima for the
warning no who's that - in the morning
long right now yeah so nothing but
nurses and doctors in the Reilly people
- but then the next day I mean
separately let's go get some more and
then we drove to three [ __ ] Popeyes
they were all [ __ ] they all right now
there's like sign that good what is it
like there's something different here
they're putting crack in that [ __ ] oh
yeah there's drugs and the best way to
jack-in-the-box better it's tender the
bread a buttery the chicken it's like
greasy the best I can describe is you
know when you take a bite of a sandwich
you can like you feel your teeth go
through layers bread and meat it's one
[ __ ] bite and you go through
everything out breads and at once bread
and chicken at once
melts in your mouth yeah I'm a skeptic
you know I'm always like those kind of
guys I mean I don't believe the -
everybody sceptic yeah I'm a sceptic
have a septic tank no youyou just
minimal minimal sauce bro if I can taste
good
oh my gosh and me I was like we
seriously we drove to check for a do way
better [ __ ] put those the shame what
makes it different the batter you know I
think it's like buttermilk fried chicken
the bread and the sauce and it's just so
tender I guess it's like pink sauce it's
that Popeye sauce but it's so good it's
a spicy yeah no no you can get spicy or
you can get a regular if I do it's just
like I said won't biting just go through
everything like
KFC's coming I was gonna be on me bein
chicken yeah well what's funny though is
that the that chicken sandwich was
released on the 12th of August and
nobody did nobody nobody said anything
and she it was the tweet from
chick-fil-a we were first in their faces
because then people start going Popeyes
has a chicken sandwich like they didn't
do their people miss old memes pape I
love gays I haven't seen Popeyes get
this much present ever ever know they're
in the South Mount
East Coast - no because they didn't used
to exist it was only was they be getting
bigger in the last ten years here -
there's more buzz only so Louisiana they
usually yeah that one in they should be
like just pioneered yeah churches a
redish you know hi turkeys biscuits
yeah the honey bunch but I've never pop
by the one of you the biscuit and the
honey right me - yeah but I've never
seen a fast-food chain restaurant and
get this much height for Huggins just
the item on your menu like this now
you're [ __ ] one like I think or the
shamrock shake people are like finally
comparing Popeyes the chick-fil-a
chicken
oh [ __ ] it's pretty much the same
Popeyes never had a sandwich before he
had their sandwich but Darren yeah the
little chicken - yeah I know they do
they still do those the little ones it
was like a like a bonus breasts wrapped
around with bacon peanuts uh Wendy's now
oh no my ex is mom used to make good huh
no this is a penis see ways
I don't know when we had that fish that
Popeye fish and I was a little bit
that's good too though but see drive to
three different locations you try get
this chicken like before if I can she
had to go to work again that's good we
drove by yesterday a Popeye's a liver
yesterday on the way home no people
setting in line you mean the one in bar
I think so because we are we got gas in
Boyle Heights
yeah she [ __ ] took all that without
yeah over the sandwich cause four bucks
399 that's G yeah compared to a
chick-fil-a or seven or eight man you
did with a sort of fries yah yah yah
Sheree laughs for one day my god that
Amish holiday rush mamushka come spring
yeah we're one bit or one week they just
do whatever they want a week it's like a
whole summer
that was like basically it was their rum
spring they were following the
government ZQ yeah please behaving and
some of them did go back because they
would be shunned from their family if
they didn't return Sean what's up boo
was so how's the Jehovah's Witness for a
bit hardcore like your hardest have that
many wise in the kitchen at once
[Laughter]
women know many women one kitchen yeah
yeah Friday Boyle Heights at there's a
gallery you know our yeah let's go oh no
Thursday I'm doing a show at the Long
Beach aquarium
it's Thursday Thursday it's a weekend
thing no no it's Thursday I'm gonna do
jokes about save each other all right
Thursday you see B colored people time 8
o'clock
viva los jokes with Martha morning on
September 10th in the bridge comedy a
comedy Levin he'll come ashore 11
o'clock right yeah the Sunday service no
no we're doing demos Josephine's
September 10th in Riverside at the life
Florida center but yeah that's his his
weekly show on Sundays he's doing the
second one he did somebody else hosted
right and then I thought I was like I
think Georgia that week cuz they were
gone
yeah they were gone or something you
know so we're gonna find out more
updates later on whatever comes in due
to due to the database will definitely
uh update you guys and see if there's a
starter from you guys right two gigs we
got winning two gigs
no no what's the name I've been hooked
up to these with them okay I gluten-free
cake that way yeah man what's up fool
take your lease expires at Marcin Rizzo
Johnny rocky and wrote real or Torres
co-host of the year bro what do you want
you to do Yemen yeah man it's out yours
bro smile by the way I worried care bro
did you say there was a guy that I paid
for your Netflix because he like
yeah so there's this guy I'm you're a
boy shout to milray yes yeah he's a fan
of podcasting he's a sponsor because he
pays for my me and Stephanie's HBO GO
wait he's just doing this out of the
kindness yeah he likes the podcast he
likes the videos turn it off
yeah so as long as I mention him every
party because yeah I mention Remo mill
radius he went to the San Jose show last
week yeah without cable you don't have
to have any cable you guys want there
are send me a dick pic all that favor
one day you guys gonna be doing your
videos in I looking for a grip guy they
were doing basically porn on snapchat
yeah oh yeah but it was nude and it was
suggestive and that do know that memo
bro he was its tattoo princess tattoo
princess it'd be like an athletic fool
like that you have to have all that [ __ ]
dude you can't not just a normal full
control princess like that and eat tacos
right tacos and she lost a bunch of
weight I think years ago she's young -
right yeah a guy that 40
what's up with her be the glittering
edge someone broke a scar on the
restroom right and then like some do
should cover the restroom with like here
like Rain Man or that curly but he was
blond we're all right and I say all
right I went oh all the restroom at the
gas station and I'm gonna tell her that
we're going when he came on the bathroom
he's got no key so they came by at least
oh and it was it sort of all in the
widow you know that fool what a fool